We have an app which has
a list of friends and
you can add those friends to the shared
list here just by clicking this button.
And you can also remove them.
Pretty cool.
So, it looks like we're effectively
keeping track of who is shared on
what lists.
So now it's time to actually
change around the user lists
to add shopping lists when
they're shared with the user.
This is a fairly complicated task.
So here's some thoughts that I
had about how to break it down.
My recommendation is that the first
thing you should do is to add or
remove a list to a users list.
So when you press the plus button.
And becomes green.
You should actually take that list and
add it to the user list of
the friend that you're sharing with.
Conversely, if you press
the green check to unshare it.
To remove the list from
your friend's user lists.
Also, a quick reminder,
whenever you're changing around who's
shared on the list, it should update the
timestamp last changed for all users.
Okay, so once you've got that working,
you can change or update map for
all with value to update the lists for
all shared users.
Right now, it's doing it pretty
effectively for the owner but you should
have this method also update for
anybody that's on the shared with list.
For updateMapForAllWithValue to actually
be able to do this, you might need to
change the signature to include
passing in a shared with list.
And since you're probably going to be
changing around that method signature,
you're also going to want to update
all the places that you call
updateMapForAllWithValue.
So that you can pass in
that shared with list.
You might find that you're calling
this method from Adapters and Dialogs.
And that gets a little bit more tricky.
Let me give you some tips.
For Adapters, you could set a list
of shared users much like you said
a shopping list in an Adapter.
Let me show you in the code.
In ActiveListItemAdapter of
a ShoppingList member variable.
And that shopping list member variable
is actually set here with this
setShoppingList method.
Okay, so now if I go over to
active list details activity,
I'm here in the onCreate method and
a lot of stuff happens.
I'm scrolling down.
But, one of the things is I get
a listener that grabs the shopping list.
So it's the activity shopping
list member variable.
And then passes in the shopping
list into the adapter.
So you could do something kind
of similar in the activity.
You can grab, in the activity,
you can grab the shared with list.
And then when that changes you
can pass that into the adapter.
Dialogs are similarly
a little bit tricky.
Now, you can pass in these shared
users into a new instance method,
much like you would a primitive value.
But shared users is a hash map,
and, if you remember,
in the new instance methods,we're
putting all those values into a bundle.
So, you might be wondering how
to put a hash map into a bundle,
well you can use Bundle's handy
dandy put Serializable method.
And similarly you can pull it out of
the bundle by using Bundle's handy dandy
get Serializable method.
You just have to remember to
also cast it to hash map.
All right so I'm not going to lie,
this is a pretty big update.
But I know you're ready for it.
Read the spec carefully,
work incrementally, and
reach out if you need help.
I'll also go ahead and
add a link to adding log level debugging
information in the instructor notes.
Okay, best of luck and
I'll send over the spec right now.